so just to kick things off can you tell
me how you got involved in directing
this
episode sure um you know basically after
the first season we had such a good
working relationship uh between the art
department and the writing team and the
creative
Executives um that kindly Uh Kevin
Wright our EP and Eric Martin our head
riter ask to join the riters room for
season two so I was in the riters room
for season two and helping to come up
with some of these kind of essential
ideas of this season and one thing led
to another and uh I got a opportunity to
direct one of the episodes the exact
episode that it was going to be was a
little tricky to figure out because it
was a function of schedule because I had
to design the whole season first so we
had to kind of see which one uh was
going to be the last one to shoot
because that was going to be the one
that was most realistic for me to direct
because most of the design work has
already been done at that stage and I
was very lucky that the one that fell to
the end of the schedule was uh 203 yeah
I mean it's definitely I feel like it's
the perfect one for you especially
because it's so design heavy and there's
so much new things to look at um but
that just takes me to my next question
which is about this whole like Chicago
World Fair it looks amazing and I'm so
glad that that you guys went there
because that's like one of my favorite
um aspects of History to look at
especially American history um but can
you talk about this season's just the
look of the season and creating the look
of this season and especially of this
episode I mean like even like the like
the production of like seeing the loom
and seeing the uh the the stage
performance I mean it was all great
thank you so much it's nice of you to
say um yeah I mean in terms of the TVA
there was a great opportunity this
season and that we're going to new
corners of the TVA that we didn't get to
see in the first season and because
we're spending a lot of our
time uh dealing with the loom and
dealing with the RNA kind of the
basically this is it's all taking place
on a level that I call the systems level
which is the like basically the
infrastructure or the foundation of the
TVA these spaces had to exist first
before the spaces that we saw in season
one could exist um you know if you think
of the temporal Loom as uh like a power
plant mixed with this
maintenance uh apparatus for organizing
time and you think of the RNA as the
kind of Nexus of of TVA technology and
maintenance these places had to exist
first so they were inspired by you know
if the first season was inspired by the
mid-60s this season was inspired by the
mid-50s as more of a cold war earlier
feeling in terms of the the pallet of
greens which are very institutional
pallet from that era to the Fortified
feeling of like a of a bunker you know
and in terms of the the World's Fair and
the 1970s we this was an episode this
was a season where we got to do some
more of that we're jumping around to
different eras and um that was super fun
to do and yeah the World's Fair was was
fantastic because it was a challenge in
that like I was saying that we spent
most of the Season we spend a lot of
time in the TVA and so when you're
building a big set that you get to use
in multiple episodes it's easy to sort
of justify the cost of it it's trickier
with the episode I ended up directing
because we're only in those sets for one
episode and yet they need to be big and
feel fully realized and flushed out so
that was just the challenge is always
you know Finding building as much as you
need but not more than you need and
finding the smartest way to to ask for
help from our brilliant VFX team led by
Chris Townsen and Sandra balage and uh
to to help us flesh out the world I mean
it definitely I think it paid off I
think it this whole season has looked
really great I love seeing all these um
like these very tangible sets it looks
uh it's amazing um but okay so looking
at this episode we finally get to meet
Victor timley in this show and he's
obviously very different from these
other versions of Kang that we've met
before which I think is great um but
what made you guys decide to focus on
this version of his character and
turning him sort of into almost like a
con man or like a trickster sure you
know I mean uh I think that we we were
sort of trying to find an interesting
new version of Kang and also one that or
Kang variant and one that would sort of
subvert expectations but most
importantly feed the needs of this
season story arc and in terms of timely
himself like um he he was just inspired
by these like the Einsteins of the world
this this archetype of this um
creative quirky thinker who's operating
on a level much you know Seven Levels
higher than everybody around him and yet
in some ways as a result is as awkward
and can't connect on a on a kind of more
basic level um so we took this person
that had all this brilliant potential in
this in form of this child and you know
then R his minutes give him this like
critical piece of super Advanced
technological knowledge that sets him on
this path um in terms of the charlatan
conment element of it like to me I've
always thought of that as like it's a
sort of a survival mechanism you know
you're talking about a black man uh
who's trying to be a an inventor in the
in the late 19th century and like the
very nature of even the World's Fair
like why is he presenting this in the
Hof brow at the Midway instead of the
machine Hall in the White City you know
um all those things were sort of part of
it and so I think it's it's it's like
he's it's a survival mechanism on the
one hand and on the other hand he's
stuck with the fact that he these ideas
are not cons his his technological
designs are truly brilliant but the
technology to execute them doesn't exist
in his era and so that's sort of where
you're seeing him stuck you know in
between yeah definitely I think that's
it's an
interesting calling it sort of a
survival mechanism I think is very
accurate because you see him he's just
like he's on the move at all times and
he's like he's not actually you know
trying to fool people I think in the way
that looki might but um I think it's an
interesting sort of play on that Dynamic
but another big twist that we see in
this episode comes in the form of Miss
minutes who I it's revealed that she has
some unrequited feelings for he who
remains and of course I K very I guess
by proxy um can you talk about digging
into that character more and making her
more human and also are we seeing the
rise of a new villain because of
this um yeah that was honestly one of
the most fun and weird curveballs we got
to chase this this season uh for me at
least and like yeah I mean this is this
idea I think we're flirting with this
notion of this like of a singularity and
this like what happens when you get an
AI That's getting too real and that's
getting too sophisticated and and and
and then in the case of Miss it's one
that's been around a long time um that's
been around since the beginning with him
and it's just there's the comedy of
seeing her show up with all this baggage
and projecting it on timely who's just a
new variant he has no context for any of
this he doesn't know what she's talking
about and she's projecting all the
baggage that she has from he who remains
on to him and then of course there's
this like triangle between her and ren
Slayer and who who you know are allies
of
convenience um they're not they're not
naturally bonded but they they need each
other and then they both par in parallel
to that relationship they they both have
their own connection to timely that's
distinct and at odds um so that was just
super fun to play with this episode yeah
I think um was definitely it surprised
me the most on my first watch but then I
was like yeah no this kind of makes
sense um and then there's this big fight
scene that we see at the end of the
episode and we see you know uh ravona
and um Loki and Mobius and Sylvie all
come together with Ely um and we've kind
of seen this throughout the episode of
Loki and Sylvie kind of facing off and
it's kind of a duplicate of their
argument from the last season which is
you know do we kill him or do we take
his place do we fix this um I'm just
curious if you fall on one side of that
argument do you think there's a right or
wrong in this response in uh their
responses well I don't know I mean I
think that it's hard to say uh I think
that they both have valid points and
because we can't know how it's going to
turn out it's hard to say either of them
are wrong but I I do feel like there's
maybe an easier way to the easier way to
say it is that there a more
empathetic um View and one that maybe we
as a as a species we're better served
taking of giving the benefit of the
doubt and and I think that like The Plea
that timely makes to
Sylvie uh that he she that he doesn't
that he is not who she says he is she
doesn't know that he's not going to
become he who remains it I think it
highlights in her the hypocrisy of her
own view that like of free will that we
have the that we have the potential to
determine our own you know Destiny and
and who we're going to become and yet
she's here to kill this man because she
thinks she assumes she knows who he's
going to become so I think that that's
generally I don't know I think the world
would be better if people made fewer
assumptions about about other people you
know yeah definitely well this was an
amazing episode and I really want to
thank you for talking with me I can't
wait to see what else you have uh in
your directing future because this was
an uh just a very fun episode to watch
and I want to thank you for uh spending
time with me thank you so much I really
appreciate
it